i get a call
from somebody i don't know who this is
this is macho man i don't know who this
is
and i get the call i pick up my phone
and says and macho misses
hey the hulkster told me you can make me
some clothes
i'm holding the phone out like who in
the hell is this what the hulkster told
me
hulkster told me you know in his heavy
voice
i have no idea who this person is i said
well we so every day come on
come tomorrow you know we're here noon
to six give them the address whatever
next day comes with elizabeth and he's
got
little shorts that
have three stars across the front and
then maybe two inch letterings across
his tush this macho man
you know i said dude i'm not making
shorts
and i need real estate i need it from
the ground to pass your head
but i'm not making sure this is not me i
need
you know you're asking me to make
clothes i'll make you some clothes but
this is not
it anyway he couldn't get to that he
says well i made a lot of money with
this and this and that and he wants
capes i said dude i'm not a cape guy
right you come to me and you say listen
i need a
uh i need a gown for my daughter that's
getting married it's twenty thousand
dollars i'll pay you
you know and then we got the bridesmaids
they're fifteen thousand
you know am i going to take your money
you know i'm gonna take your money yes
b roman numeral michael he doesn't wear
dresses he doesn't think about dresses
he doesn't think about weddings he's got
no idea what you're talking about this
whole
women's wedding what the hell are you
even
i got nothing i'm nobody home
but i can go buy modern bride i can just
look at a picture i can go draw the
thing
i'll make the first one and the sewers
will make the ones after that
and the story here's your twenty
thousand dollar gown but you're not
getting the best from mike because mike
has no idea what you're talking about
i mean none um
so randy i make him
a few outfits to just get him started
now he comes to the shop again puts his
head down
he says you can make anything you want
this is the kiss
kiss of death to say to someone creative
do whatever you want and not even put a
price on it or a time
anything something you can do whatever
you want
i make him five outfits and it's
him telling me the story i make him the
five outfits
and he tells me he wears his the one
that he really likes he never told me he
didn't like anything
ever which he had to have not liked
something or didn't get something or
didn't realize something was as cool
you know that i thought it was cool and
it turned out that the public thought it
was cool he didn't think it was cool but
then he got into it that they liked it
um so now
he tells this story that he's got the
five outfits he wears his favorite
outfit on monday night raw and that's
the second week third week now we're up
to the fifth week he doesn't say he wore
the outfit that he didn't like but it's
the fifth week
it's the purple outfit with the chains i
said okay
i'm listening to the story and he's
trying to paint a picture for me
purple hat with the chains he says
i put on the outfit in a separate
dressing room
i walk out of the dressing room now i'm
in the main room where
all the boys are these are like old
ladies who play marjon
these wrestlers meaning you can only
lift weights you can only travel
and you can only travel and you can only
um
you can only lift weights travel and
wrestle so much then
the rest you just gossip you know so and
so did this
you know you got 20 guys sitting around
a room with
nothing to do they gossip and this is
before cell phones
so they just gossip he walks out of the
room they all turn they go
wow where'd you get that that's great
he's going it's the one i didn't like
i thought this is nothing they freaked
out
now he's walking down the aisle down the
card or he tells me vince mcmahon is
coming the other way
vince stops him and says the hell is
that that's great
wow where'd you get it now he's going
wow now i'm really in trouble now vince
loves it
now he tells me he's standing in the
opening to walk out to the ring
he walks through the opening they put
the spotlight on him he said and it
really pops
this is his word really pops and he
really gets over
meaning he does well right connecting to
the audience that night
really got over brother exactly
and all i'm saying to you is that
he was telling me he has no idea what
the hell i'm doing
but go for it and another time
and another time meaning i'm making
probably 45 outfits a year
at 800 to 2500 a piece
and everyone in the documentary
on a e said that randy was really cheap
and he wouldn't buy a cup of coffee and
this and that
he never mentioned money i just told him
you know tony came up with
you know get a deposit so we got the 4
000 deposit to begin with
you know and that worked for a while and
then she said you got to go up to 10
grand mike get another six
you know whatever she'd tell me i would
do meaning she could see this thing
from a outsider's point of view from
this is strictly business and you said
how do you know the price
when we first started to talk
she and i made a list
how much fabric is in it how long did it
take to buy the fabric how long did it
take to
design it how long did it take to make
the pattern how long did it take to cut
it
what was veera's price to put the thing
together
um how much time to paint it how much
time to make the pattern for the
painting
macho man macho man macho man how much
for the glitter how much for the paint
you know on and on and on and
so we'd go through that long list of
stuff
and this is when we first started to
fool around with computers
um that's susan's fault totally so
you're talking about 1996
and so i made this piece of paper that
you would
write in took an hour and a half to cut
it
it took this much to buy the fabric this
is what the fabric cost
here's vera here's whatever anyway
as we're doing it we're figuring out
that this is what's going on but then we
also said
tony would sometimes say is does it look
like it's
you know twenty five hundred dollars or
two thousand dollars or one thousand
dollars i'd say
yeah it comes out to 1500 but it looks
like it's really
you know 12. or it comes out to 12 but
we should
charge 1800. you understand what i'm
saying
um but it all meant nothing to him
except to say he says to me in the shop
we're alone
it's a 30 foot by 30 foot room concrete
floor as i said there's thread
everywhere fabric everywhere clothes
being made
patterns hanging fabric on
rolls under this table under that table
on hanging on this shelf and that shelf
and whatever it's i mean just
there's nothing fancy about this it's
just business
and
his point of view
on this game is that
we're doing the best that we can he sees
that we're making a huge effort
he says to me just out of nowhere
i'm small
i'm a big mouth as you see and i'm
looking around like what the hell
how do i answer this question his arm is
bigger than both of my thighs together
right what do i say did he mean that he
was short
you figured it out see i didn't figure
it out i didn't even get this
i think what the hell is he talking
about
i don't know what he's talking about
i'll just leave it alone i say nothing
then like a week later
wwf comes to wrestle at the university
in tampa i go there i go up into the
balcony
and i look what are they seeing meaning
i'm trying to see what is the audience
seeing
and i'm taking pictures of every outfit
we make of randy's
i tell them go outside i take a few
pictures
from the front from the side from the
back meaning i want to say
ink on paper what does it look like
what does this outfit actually look like
wow so these is
so absurd you said the right thing
brother
i mean it's it's amazing the amount of
just creativity that you put into this